all right it is time for the friday
mailbag you can email info
davidpakman.com if you have something
you'd like to say ask a complaint
whatever the case may be also anytime
you post on youtube or reply to us on
twitter or whatever it might end up
featured in the mailbag you just never
know but let's get into the first one
colin wrote in with a beautiful
anti-semitic conspiracy theory colin
wrote in about the causer influence in
u.s politics saying david if you really
had any intake intention of being a good
american patriot
please check out your relatives dealings
in u.s politics obviously you won't and
dare not that's colin now this is
something called the causar myth
this is an anti-semitic trope
it has been largely abandoned although
some really hardcore anti-semites still
talk about it the idea is that ashkenazi
jews like me
whose lineage goes to eastern europe
that are our lineage is basically fake
and that we i really descended from
causers who are a multi-ethnic
turkic peoples
semi-nomadic and blah blah blah
basically the idea is even the people we
claim to be
is a lie this has been extraordinarily
widely debunked it's nonsense uh only
the most hardcore anti-semites still
push it but that's colin and we do have
some of them in our audience that's for
sure
rob wrote in and says david sir the new
haircut looks
spectacular
when you go to your stylist what exactly
do you ask for love the show keep up the
good work that's robin cincinnati well
listen rob i've been going to the same
uh hairdresser for over a decade
so at this point she says
same thing just shorter i go yep same
thing we've been doing and then that's
really it but if i had to start from
scratch i think what i would say is
uh i part my hair on this side i want
scissors all around no no buzzers or
clippers other than for the sideburns
and you know the back of my neck um and
just kind of this is this is the shape
or maybe i would even take a screenshot
of my show
and say this is the haircut i'm looking
for i think that's the best advice i can
offer
alex wrote in about people making guns
at home
a recent horrible shooting
guns were made at home
and alex says hey david i just heard
your good point about people making guns
at home however this got me thinking
about how absurd this situation is for
example
terrorists make their bombs at home so
should bombs be legal because we can't
stop literally all bomb attacks should
theft be legal because we can't stop all
thieves should murder be legal because
we can't catch all murderers mitigation
and deterrent are words that exist yeah
on the entire so after the shooting
where the i don't even remember which
one it was because there's so many
was it the july fourth one where the gun
the guns were made were made at home
okay
um you had some people on the right the
pro-gun people saying this is why gun
control does nothing
you can't stop people
if they're really determined from
getting guns they can just make them at
home and of course the reaction is oh
i'm sorry it was the japanese shooting
the japanese shooting the assassination
of former prime minister shinzo abe and
the thing was you can barely buy guns in
japan but they just made them at home
if in the united states
every would-be shooter and i'm talking
about
individual homicides mass shootings and
suicides if every would-be shooter in
the united states
could only get access to a firearm by
making it at home
the number of shootings would go down
dramatically
dramatically i know what you're saying
well but
you could make the gun at home yes
most people don't know how to do it
many who could research it to figure it
out would say that's too much work i
don't want to do that and the number of
people who would be dissuaded from
shooting anyone if they had to make
their gun at home
uh is an incredible number
and sure somebody will make their gun at
home i understand but the whole point as
alex points out here is mitigation and
deterrent and if you had to make a gun
in order to shoot someone
uh
number of shootings goes down
dramatically
dustin says
about my um commentary on jesse lee
peterson being homophobic
but also being gay dustin says lethal
take down and all totally true however
you end the clip by saying you're
uncomfortable with peterson's role as a
counselor to young men the implication
is your discomfort storms stems from him
being gay i don't think this matches
your values and it's a terrible thing to
imply that is not at all what i meant
the reason i'm uncomfortable with jessie
lee peterson mentoring young men is
because he does this thing that many in
the religious community do which is
they're not therapists they're
completely unlicensed to be in that role
but they loosely use the term counseling
sometimes they use coaching
that's what i have a problem with
not the fact that he's gay and in
general the type of i mean listen he was
doing anti-gay christian counseling i'm
against anti-gay christian counseling
whether the counselor
is gay or straight okay so dustin please
don't attribute to me things that i very
clearly didn't say
eric wrote in and said tell the truth
pacman
biden's inflation caused a recession as
consumers tightened their belts people
react to high prices by cutting back on
food and travel this news is nothing to
celebrate
uh there is no evidence of that
there's no evidence of that if you
believe that the coveted stimulus that
biden did caused inflation
then you've got to blame trump doubly
because trump had two of those
packages of stimuli
um
packages of stimulus i guess it would be
and also we're seeing the inflation
globally
so um
this is just a completely baseless claim
and there's a lot of them floating
around people aren't
limited
by the facts when they make claims
basic dad
says why doesn't pacman simply move to
venezuela
where can live in peace and harmony with
those who agree with his socialist
viewpoint does do you think this person
knows a damn thing about me
number one i'm not a socialist
number two
i don't like the chavez maduro regime of
venezuela i think they're terrible in
fact there's people in my audience who
love the regime and are mad at me that i
don't like it
i think that it's a disastrous regime
uh that has
eliminated the independence of courts
and in some cases media
that has raped and pillaged the
country's resources for their gain not
that of its population i think that
they're horrible so maybe someone who
likes venezuela and is a socialist wants
to move there but i'm good basic dad
thank you
clown rhoden
clown says i'm going to issue a dire
warning to musk pacman and all of
trump's critics out there if you do not
want to go to prison or a re-education
camp i would refrain from any more
criticism of donald trump i say this
because there's a very good chance that
he can become president again and with
the way the country is going i truly
believe trump is going to be hell bent
on revenge for his enemies
i know that may sound absolutely insane
but it is very plausible that something
like that could easily happen if trump
gets back into the white house anyone
who was speaking in a negative way
against trump i believe i believe
will be imprisoned and sent to a camp
so here's my thought clown
i don't deny for a second
that trump would love to do that if he
became president again
but i don't think he's going to
i think he uh will fail to do that
but your sense of the instincts trump
would have
i can't disagree with
last one today is from john john says i
see mr pakman playing the victim mr
pakman trolls every trump rally
but when someone trolls him he has to
make a deal about it i wonder why mr
pakman didn't troll 2 000 mules for only
30 seconds actually we we looked at like
15 minutes of 2000 mules it's a joke
2000 mules trolls itself i don't even
really have to do anything
john goes on mr pacman's narrative is
getting destroyed as americans are more
concerned with the inflation and gas
prices and the terrible rise in crime in
mostly all the democrat runned
areas
democrat-run areas we've talked about
inflation
gas prices are coming down quite quickly
uh
crime in democratic cities you know
crime is in cities cities tend to be
democratic safe cities are run by
democrats less safe cities are run by
democrats it's a very old trope and also
important by crime rate
the crime rates are often high
in rural and suburban conservative areas
but
narrative right that definitely
gets in the way of a good narrative
send in your messages info
davidpakman.com
they may be used on a future show and
remember that tuesday july 26th at 6 pm
eastern is the next david pakman show
viewer town hall we'll stream live on
pacman live
hope to see you there and we'll see you
on today's bonus show